Oh squirrel was already dead she was  already dead  he's already in school having lost not  me he was already dead  margot robbie only looks that good  because of her professional makeup  artist okay  I'll definitely work out this week I  walked two blocks so I turn this candy  what food is cheaper saving money this  way I'm definitely gonna have a salad  later you'll be single gives me time to  focus on myself  I'm only Facebook stalking my ex to stay  in the now that probably won't last  we're just going through a rough patch  every couple goes through that if one  glass of wine is good for me another is  probably equally as healthy he's only  dating her because he doesn't know he's  gay yet 2017 is gonna be a good year the  country will be fine that the president  doesn't have how much power anyway  and I think this week's the week I  finally get it all together  [Music]  yeah hello Mike okay